breaking news sources telling Fox News
that former Marine Daniel penny has just
been indicted by a grand jury in the
Chokehold death of homeless man Jordan
Neely aboard a New York City subway
train Brian yenas has the very latest
hey Brian hey Dana will we expected the
vote to happen today and it did
according to two sources the grand jury
has voted to indict Daniel Penny the 24
year old Marine veteran will now face
trial for the Chokehold death of Jordan
Neely the 30 year old homeless mentally
ill man that Witnesses say was
threatening passengers on board that New
York City subway last month we don't
know the exact charges that is being
indicted on yet but he was facing a
second-degree manslaughter charge this
grand jury had been hearing evidence and
witness testimony on this case since May
31st they weren't considering whether
Penny was guilty or not guilty but
rather whether there was enough legally
sufficient evidence and reasonable cause
to believe that a crime had been
committed here the bar for indictment is
low they only needed 12 of the 23 Grand
jurors to vote Yes to indict and they
have there will now be a trial the
Manhattan district attorney Alvin Bragg
says said that they believed there was
enough evidence witness interviews
photos videos in this case to prove that
Penny recklessly caused the death of
Neely by keeping him in the Chokehold
even after he stopped moving it took 11
days for the DA's office to charge Penny
and the charge came only after days of
protests in New York City from activists
who were outraged that Penny was not
immediately arrested and charged Penny's
attorneys were reportedly planning on
allowing him to testify in front of this
grand jury which would have been a rare
and bold move but but Fox News learned
that Penny did not in fact testify into
this grand jury now Penny's attorneys
did release video clips dated to the
press a few days ago in which the Marine
veteran defends himself saying he and
fellow passengers were scared of Neely
and that he only meant to restrain not
kill
Jordan Neely if he is found guilty in a
trial he faces up to 15 years in prison
if in fact the charge is that
second-degree manslaughter charge Brian
Yanez thank you and just days ago Daniel
Penny was speaking out and defending his
actions he claims Jordan Neely was
making threats
the three main threats that he repeated
over and over was I'm gonna kill you
I'm prepared to go to jail for life and
I'm willing to die we were all scared Mr
Neely was yelling in these passengers
faces and they looked terrified
the reason why there was no video at the
start of the altercation was because
people were too afraid getting away from
him Penny also saying that the incident
had nothing to do with race
some people say that this is about race
which is absolutely ridiculous
I didn't see a black man threatening
passengers I saw a man threatening
passengers
that's a lot of whom were people of
color
a man who out restrained Mr Neely was
was a person of color
a few days after the incident I I read
in the papers that a woman of color came
out and called me hero what I don't
believe that I'm I'm a hero but uh she
was one of those people that I was
trying to protect right so this news
just breaking Greg to get indicted in
Alvin Braggs New York you have to try to
stop a crime from happening except you
get indicted yes there you go by the way
uh Penny's wrong it is about race that's
what they're going to make it in the
media about race uh I think the
indictment's expected this is a
political case because we've politicized
safety at the Hard left as politicized
safety you can no longer defend yourself
and you can no longer defend others
because the person you were defending
against is quote homeless mentally ill
person never mind that he's also a
violent
self-destructive felon who beat women
and children the spin will always be
homeless mentally ill black man and the
only villains in these stories are going
to be white even though a black Marine
would have done the same thing as Penny
did because Marines tend to do the right
and the risky thing and speaking of risk
we are we are really lucky that we will
never have to be in a situation where we
have to choose between saving the lives
of others and a murder charge or a man
slaughter charge but we should also be
lucky that someone like Daniel Penny
will be there because we're too chicken
not to do what he does right people were
grateful uh grateful for his actions one
way to prevent this whole thing from
ever happening Alvin Brad should really
think about this when he goes home at
night maybe lock up maybe lock up in a
prison or in a hospital deranged felons
like the deceased if you don't do that
then we need some sort of transparency
uh everyone who comes into contact with
the person like that needs to know that
so if you're willing to let them out
you know these these these wild arranged
people into the general population that
we have a right to know that and that
means if you want to give them the
freedom it should come with a blinking
armband or a Brink a blinking ankle
bracelet right because at least they're
free that'll suffice similar incident
just happened uh this week and it's
happening a lot people are trying to
step in because you have Brazen unstable
individuals terrorizing people and the
cops are either not there or their hands
are literally metaphorically tied uh
once you take away the rights to defend
yourselves after paralyzing the police
what do you expect I want to give credit
for this phrase because it was not mine
Paul Morrow who you've seen on the show
before these or all the shows he's said
Jesse that this is one of those cases
where it's about class not race and it's
the Uber class versus the subway class
so you have people who take the subway
who know what it's like and have to deal
with it every day and so when this does
go to trial if it does the jury of his
peers will be people who are made up of
either a mix of those or probably more
people who ride the Subway daily and
might be sympathetic and the Uber class
used to be the subway class but the
subway is too dangerous so now they're
paying more to ride Uber
they'll probably erect a statue of Neely
why not he's a deranged violent drug
addict let's take down Teddy Roosevelt
and put something up of him I'm sure
either it's Trump or DeSantis all of the
Republican candidates for president are
say they're going to Pardon this guy if
he's convicted I'm sure he's got a nice
fat GoFundMe page going because he
deserves all the help he can get and I
hope from the bottom of my heart that
there's one New Yorker with the heart on
this jury that can make sense of this
thing now let's look at it through race
let's do it right you have a white guy
protecting black people from a black guy
and a black prosecutor wants to put that
white guy in jail think about that for a
second and it's a lot of these cases
it's McCluskey it's ritten house and now
it's Penny they don't want you to defend
yourself they don't want you to even
have a firearm and think about being a
marine you sign up you say I'm going to
sacrifice everything I'm going to go do
push-ups every day shave my head put my
life on the line to defend all of these
people and what this is the thanks he
gets he comes back and protects people
the way he was doing in the Marine Corps
and a slovenly prosecutor for political
reasons tries to put this guy in prison
this is a miscarriage of Justice if it
goes down like this and I hope everybody
on the Republican side makes that
promise we don't have yet at least
answers to a couple of things I don't
believe Jessica that we have seen the
toxicology report of melee which might
be something good for everyone to see
and I'm sure it will come out in in the
jury and also penny has every incentive
to fight this his next court appearance
is June 17th so that's just a few days
away but he could he could spend so much
time behind bars if this goes against
him so you will see
perhaps a landmark case in New York City
just because of the climate that we're
in the crime situation that we're in and
now every once in a while a case like
this comes around
there'll certainly be a lot of interest
in it and I think he said it was up to
15 years in prison which is a really
long time but in defense of Alvin Bragg
bringing charges and having to bring
this to a grand jury a man is dead right
if this had been some sort of attack and
Jordan Neely when he was put into the
recovery position popped up and the cops
came and they took him away that would
be one thing but someone did die and
judge Puro when we were talking about
this pointed that out that it obviously
makes it more complicated to just go oh
Daniel penny is a hero and walk away
because there is someone who is no
longer alive as a result of that whether
his life is as meaningful to some people
as a former Marine someone who served
our country
you know I'm not one to make that kind
of judgment but this is someone who had
a tragic life we know about what
happened his mother chopped up and put
in a bag and found on the side of a
highway was in the top 50
um most at risk lists for homeless
people
arrested had beaten up older women yeah
and so I happened to think that if this
goes to trial when this goes to trial
that they will rule in favor of Daniel
penny that he did see us rat that he was
protecting people and that it is a
tragic mistake here but you can't just
ignore the fact that somebody died
and act like you should just put a medal
on him and walk away
well I didn't call him a hero he didn't
call himself a hero you did yeah I
didn't call him a hero okay
I think it's a medal if I run that train
I absolutely would and I would well and
I'm curious also okay just there's one
other thing that we don't know that was
my shoes sorry
um the there were two people who
assisted penny at the time right uh were
they Witnesses at the Grand Jury where
were they going to be charged as well
they they we don't have the details of
what the grand jury decided but we
haven't heard that they are also being
charged as accessories to this situation
um you know Jordan Neely died as a
result of his behavior he died because
he was on the train threatening to kill
people and people like Daniel Penny
decided that and the two others that
they weren't going to be the ones who
were victims of that and they weren't
going to allow innocent women possibly
children elderly people on that train to
be victims of what he was threatening to
do and now he's being punished for it
and it's interesting to watch the
argument play out and how the left sees
heroes in Jordan Neely and giving people
some kind of pass for this kind of
violent Behavior because they're
mentally ill or had a tough life and
that's what Alvin Bragg thinks that's
how his whole criminal justice
philosophy that's what's what it's built
on versus Daniel Penny who served his
country is on a train sees people being
violently accosted with with words and
threats and decides to do something
about it and the thing that this will
result in is more innocent victims of
crimes because nobody wants to be
charged with manslaughter nobody wants
to be dragged through the media circus
of the racial issue and so it only is
going to result in a worse situation for
people who ride the subway and innocent
people are just trying to make an honest
living and get to work can I just add
quickly though I I don't think that
people see Jordan Neely as a hero his
GoFundMe page she'll point about
gofundme's so Daniel pennies has
millions of dollars and Jordan Neely's
capped out at about a hundred thousand
dollars people are are not buying into
this in the same way as other
utter tragedies like what happened with
a George Floyd and I understand at the
beginning there was a race to try to
make it like that but I think that
people see it for what it is hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else